domaine de l'alimentation a fait des
potes géant 20 ans et la façon nous
vendre les produits pendant tout ce
temps là a beaucoup évolué et séduction
information à vous de voir
[Musique]
en 20 ans c'est incroyable chemin
parcouru je pense qu'on est de plus en
plus sophistiqués aller chatouiller les
cordes sensibles des consommateurs
le monde de la mise en marché des
produits alimentaires est en constante
mutation les clientèles évolué et
l'industrie s'adapte continuellement
pour la première fois dans l'histoire on
a quatre groupes démographiques de
consommateurs qui se côtoient sur la
place publique sur le marché
c'est-à-dire les baby boomers la
génération suivante comme la mienne et
milena rios et puis la génération z
auquel j'enseigne ici à concordia donc
18 avait été un an avec des ddd des
chaînes de valeur très différent
lorsqu'on achète lorsqu'on se nourrit on
n'a pas la même façon de penser la même
phase on prend des décisions que le baby
boomer qui fait face à d'autres enjeux
il faut bien réaliser que ce sont des
comptes différents et à l'intérieur de
ces groupes là on a des sous groupes on
a le millénaire you qui est très
friand de marquer qui s'affiche avec ses
marques et à d'autres qui au contraire
sont pas très orientée vers les marques
c'est aussi des gens qui sont très
conscients de l'impact de leur choix on
va voir des entreprises responsables
vont vouloir savoir un peu le pedigree
derrière l'entreprise on aime
on va en même temps se laisser séduire
par des influenceurs des porte paroles
qui vont venir le dire et c'est ça c'est
super cool c'est super bon donc il ya un
peu de dichotomie là dedans vous avez
peut-être déjà remarqué de plus en plus
globaux à caractère santé sur les
produits mais ils ne représentent pas
nécessairement des choix santé depuis
les débuts de l'épicerie il ya 20 ans
nous avons été témoin de cette évolution
et nous avons bien souvent sonné
l'alerté
et environ 15 20 ans on était beaucoup
dans le sang le sang cholestérol le sans
gras trans le sans sucre même société
très très plaisant identifier les
ennemis depuis quelques années les
grands de l'alimentation ont fait preuve
de beaucoup d'imagination pour répondent
les selles a été dans la mire aussi très
très longtemps ensuite est venu les
calories tout court comme un ennemi puis
deux puis plus récemment on a vu les
colorants les additifs ou si ton neveu
beaucoup s'il est sans colorant ou sans
saveur artificielle tout ce qui était
artificielle on est passé par une
tendance soucis qu'ils étaient allés
vers le naturel on veut des couleurs
naturelles des saveurs naturelles on
veut moins d'additifs dans les listes
d'ingrédients on cherche la naturalité
la cour exactement on cherche de plus en
plus des aliments qui ressemble à ce
qu'on peut se faire soi même ou avec des
ingrédients qu'on a à la maison c'est
sûr que les produits alimentaires de
l'industrie baisse à à d'autres et il
faut que ça dure plus longtemps sur les
tablettes il faut que ça l'est une telle
tendreté telle saveur tout sauf que
c'est sûr que on travaille pas avec les
mêmes impératifs mais c'est quand même
ce qu'on recherche donc présentement le
marketing alimentaire attire notre
attention sur les courtisent
d'ingrédients le sans additifs sans
colorant juste
un des arguments populaire depuis vingt
ans et la praticité et le marketing suis
beaucoup les tendances des habitudes et
les besoins du consommateur et on sait
qu'on a besoin de cuisiner vite que leur
poste rapidement prêt soit nutritifs
aussi pour toute la famille alors oui le
marketing nous amène beaucoup le côté
savez près en 5 minutes ou vos micros en
douce et dans des combats avec lesquels
on peut manger marketing nous martèle le
message que savait plus rapide si on
défend de boîtes comme un saut au four
et si on se fait soit même si un saumon
soul ii soul grippe il va être en dix
minutes
l'industrie suit les tendances mais les
devants souci elle doit prévoir deux ou
trois en avance ce qui va plaire un
consommateur de plus en plus exigeants
on parle du citoyen consommateur et on
reconnaît de plus en plus que le
consommateur n'est pas qu'un
consommateur il est un citoyen qui fait
partie d'une communauté et il a le bien
de sa communauté à cars et peut jouer un
rôle d'agent de changement avec de plus
en plus qu'il en soit conscient
pleinement ou non conscient c'est que le
consommateur lorsqu'il achète quelque
chose lorsqu'il s'est il l'a brûlée mais
un produit dans son panier il exprime
une portion de ses valeurs et son
identité un
certain entreprises bousculer standard
de l'industrie pour se démarquer on voit
beaucoup surtout parmi les startups et
les jeunes entrepreneurs cette notion de
vouloir défaire les codes 1 de vouloir
aller à contre-courant parfois et puis
faut admettre que ça paye parce que ça
fait qu'on nous remarquons dia maintien
juge pas habitués à voir un tel ou tel
produit de telle ou telle couleur alors
on peut venir jouer là dessus il ya des
opportunités de se tailler une place en
étant un peu plus créatifs en jouant à
contre-courant la nouvelle tendance
s'oriente davantage vers les tic vers
l'environnement et tout ça le
consommateur devient plus conscients 8
de certains enjeux mais parfois plus
d'anxieux lui si on veut diminuer
l'emballage on veut diminuer l'empreinte
carbone on veut tout faire ça mais on ne
plaint les épaules comme consommateur
comme parents faisons des lunch pour les
enfants comme travailleurs qui devront
aussi sait concilier la famille le
travail et les loisirs est tout seul
on met beaucoup de poids le fardeau sur
les épaules du consommateur de
s'informer de se renseigner de voir au
delà des artifices de la couverture du
produit pour vraiment dire baisse que ce
produit là est à la hauteur des attentes
et des premières ce qui le fait
et que nous réserve l'avenir toute la
notion d'alimentation durable qui est
très globale parce que ça touche la
santé ça touche l'environnement ça
touche l'économie ça touche les ticos un
animal que des travailleurs aussi donc
tout ce qui est englobée dans
l'alimentation durable ça ne fait que
commencer je pense que on encore pour
des amis à voir cette tendance
[Musique]